طمعا في الثراء السريع طلب منه ذبح ابنه
وتقديم دمه قربانا للجن لفتح مقبره اثريه
ولكن رفضت زوجته تضحيتها بطفلها فكان
جزاؤها القتلى بعده طعنات
[موسيقى]
اللي حصل بالظبط
بتبقى هابطه في الارض يعني كده شويه كان
عنده فرسه وبتاع جتا ماتت وكذا حاجه بتموت
في المكان ده
المكان ده فيه اثار
[موسيقى]
بيدور على الاثار دي في بيته بس هو محمد
والله يضحك ابوه بابنه ومراته بالدنيا
كلها طالما ونس اللي فوق المدور على تحت
الارض وما فيش حاجه تحت الارض هنسى الدنيا
كلها
هل هو فعلا كان عايز يقتل ابنه الاول طبعا
طلب منها وطبعا ما فيش مره اصلا انها
توافق هتدي ابنها اذا كان حاطه عمره يوم
واحد ما فيش
طبعا هو ده خلاص العقل غايب واديني غايب
وكله غايب خلاص
ليه بيتم قتل حد وتقديم دم وقربان يعني
ايه الفكره عشان تفتح المقبره كانت الجن
طالب دم تمام هقول لك عليها جن وعليها مش
عارف ايه تمام طالبين دم عشان تفتح
المقبره تفتح الباب
دم ابنك يعني حد يعني قريب منك عزيز عليك
قوي يعني
اليوم اللي عرفت فيه ان اختك توفت وصل لك
الخبر ازاي كانت عندي بقى يوم الحد وسبع
يوم اللي كان سابع الاربع ولا سبع الخميس
ابن خالي جنادها اللي من المحل قال لي
تعال عايزك في المستشفى رحت المستشفى تمام
رحت هناك دلوقتي ماشي
واخده ضربات في جسمها كله
والخبطات
هنلاقي جسمها بارد
دي متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات